- YouTube, what's up?
So so grateful that you clicked
and you're about to
watch a new YouTube video
but before you do 212-931-5731.
That is my texting community platform,
I'm doing a lot of one on
one engagement in there,
and also access opportunity,
first looks in that environment.
212-931-5731,
join it now and now to the video
you've been wanting to watch.
And I'm saying this not
to do anything other than,
because I know D-Rock
is recording right now,
and I'm going to air this in 10 years
on whatever the Instagram of the day is
to say I told you so.
I promise you that in
a decade, 15 years max,
brand, your brand is going to be the
only thing that matters besides
the quality of your product,
everything else in the
middle, will be commoditized.
And as.
(hip instrumental music)
You got your perspective.
I just want to be happy,
don't you want to be happy?
Super excited to be here.
There's a lot of a lot of
things I like to talk about.
First and foremost I'm going to spend
a couple minutes to create
context of my background,
because I think it will really resonate
with the far majority of this room
by growing up in retail and thinking about
customer account and average receipt size
and things of that nature.
When I got into the media landscape
after building a very large wine retail
and e-commerce business, no question,
the sector or one of the key sectors that
I've always felt closest to is this space.
We've had the luxury at
my advertising agency,
over the last decade to work with a lot of
fast casual QSRs have invested
in a lot of that space.
My business partner Matt
Hagen's who's on Shark Tank
and with RSC does a ton in
the food space so this is,
this is very, you know, it's funny,
I can always feel my own chemicals,
I feel so cozy this morning in this room,
because I think a lot about the stuff that
I think a lot of people here think about,
and more importantly, I
think the thing that gives
me the great privilege
to be on stage right now
is I've historically thought
about the end consumer,
in a way over the last 20 years that
has allowed me to have
hypothesis and opinions
and executions that
haven't seemed as obvious
to the people within that sector,
and then has had, you know,
historical correctness,
and so I sit here today at this conference
very excited because I
believe that we are living
in a very interesting time of society
and consumer norms, completely
and utterly predicated
on the fact that the
internet is now mature,
but you know when I look around this room.
There's a vast majority
of us that actually
remember our lives pre-internet.
You know, I went through
all of high school,
you know, up to 18 years old spending
less than 15 hours on a
computer in my entire life.
I probably spend 15 hours on a computer
every day now with my phone,
and so the biggest thing that I want to
start this conversation
with is the following.
Please understand that the internet is now
only about 20 to 25 years
old as a consumer product,
and is now hit scale
in a way that I believe
the far majority of this
room is under estimating,
not only the way consumers
consume information
to make decisions on
purchasing your products,
but more importantly, I would
be flabbergasted if this room
isn't already trying to
anticipate things like Last Mile,
things like Cloud Kitchens,
things like that are really
going to impact this room,
all of which leads this to one
very large conversation
around, really, the elephant
in the room which is the
internet eliminates the middle.
That's what it does by nature,
the internet is actually the
middleman, the middle woman.
And over time, every industry
and sector will feel that,
I actually am really excited
to be here this morning
because what my speeches tend to do
is reach one or two
individuals in a room like this
to actually change behavior.
And the timing of this talk reminds me of
two significant talks
I've given in my career,
from a timing standpoint,
four years ago, at a retail conference
and six years ago, believe it or not,
at the Black Taxi and
Limo Conference, and one,
obviously, as you can imagine
was me talking six years
ago about Uber and watching the collective
naivete and audacity of the room
on how much it wasn't going to affect them
versus how much it ended up affecting them
and then four or five
years ago trying to get
people to understand
that the growth of direct
to consumer purchasing at the retail level
was really on the cusp.
And again, because the
internet had been around
for a while, and Nordstrom
had a dot com for a decade,
and things of that nature,
the room really misunderstood
what has transpired
over the last three years, which is why
we're seeing so much
disruption at the retail level,
because the cost of goods,
in actual real estate
and the COGs to operate
a retailer that has 100%,
you know brick and mortar
with an emerging dot com
four or five years ago was
a humongous vulnerability,
compared to consumer behaviors,
let it be very clear for this
room and I know it is already,
even though I don't think it's sustainable
with the delivery services
with the economics
both for them and for you.
I think you all understand
that the consumer
wants in a certain way,
the consumer doesn't care how we spend
our money on our locations, or where,
consumer cares about what
consumer cares about.
The only reason I think I've
been successful in business
is I've never had a day
and this is natural DNA,
this wasn't taught this
is the luck of the draw
of how I was created,
there's never been a day
where I've ever thought about what's
in it for me with my businesses.
Every single thing I
think about every day is,
what do they think, like
why is that good for them,
what are they actually doing.
And so, let's break that down.
Right now, there's a
couple things I believe in
that I highly recommend
the majority of this room
gets much more serious about.
Prepping for this, understanding
some of the companies
in the room both, both the emergers,
and kind of the iconics.
One thing I can promise
you is that an enormous
percentage of marketing money being spent
in this industry,
franchisors, franchisees,
self owned, brand level,
an enormous percentage
of the money is going
directly in the trash.
And I think, thank you, thank you mom.
(audience laughing)
This is happening in the macro.
This is happening in every industry.
And so this isn't some wild different
thing that's happening in our sector,
but it is shocking to
me and as you guys know,
as private equity has rolled
very deeply into this industry,
because I had a lot of street cred
and relationships in that world,
I've been looking even
deeper at, you know,
the dollars being spent
and it's and it's scary,
let's actually play this exercise.
It's a good fresher upper in the morning,
get us moving a little bit.
By show of hands, how
many people in this room,
now, when they watch
television, mainly watch
Netflix, Hulu, Amazon or if
they're watching a network show,
it's DVR-ed and they're
watching it on their time.
Don't be lazy, raise your
hands high, raise them.
Okay now I need you to keep them up,
please keep it up
because I see some of you
dropping it, please just for me.
Everybody in the front, look because
everybody just kind of look around.
I think we can all
agree that this is not a
14 year old girl crowd, right?
You can put it down.
I just want everybody
understand what just happened.
90% of the hands just went up, which means
90% of this audience isn't even capable
of consuming a commercial,
isn't even capable.
For the rest of us who during live sports
or during the 10% of hands that went up,
I think we can all agree that the second a
commercial comes on television,
we all grab this and do
something we actually
want to do in those 30, 60,
two minutes, during that time,
billions of dollars are
being spent on TV commercials
and in 2020, nobody's consuming them.
Super Bowl, on the other
hand, I would argue,
every, if I actually knew your business
and knew your budget,
if you could afford it.
I would spend there first
before all the things
I believe in on Instagram
or Facebook or YouTube
because you get 100% consumption
by the American population.
So, this is not a digital
versus traditional argument.
This is why do we not
market with common sense
in a 2019 environment?
We live in a world where a
lot of the justifications
at the highest company
levels are completely
and utterly predicated on
reporting potential impressions,
you know, Millward Brown
and Nielsen, reporting,
just complete and utter
elimination of common sense.
We've now, this is, and by the way
I stand up here with no hypothesis,
we have now run multiple
AV tests with multiple QSRs
and fast casuals where we run Facebook
and Instagram isolated on content,
and then we run remnant
TV, direct mail, and radio,
and it's not even close.
The problem is, 99% of
companies have not taken
the time and effort to
actually do an honest A B test.
At the highest level somebody
makes an arbitrary decision,
one way or the other, or more importantly,
and this is very important for this room,
if you leave with anything
hear this very carefully.
It is wildly easy to waste a ton of money
doing digital marketing.
This is not blanket statement.
I watch people, I believe that Facebook
is so grossly under priced for
45 to 90 year old Americans,
and you can run incredible arbitrage
on traffic results, whatever you want,
but I watch people
every day waste $100,000
on Facebook and get no return.
The ROI of an execution is
predicated on your talent,
not on the platform.
You know the ROI of a
basketball for me is negative,
I have to torn meniscuses,
the ROI of a basketball for LeBron James
is billions of dollars.
You know, this is very
interesting times right now.
So, number two, when we start getting
into the digital conversation,
the thing that I think disproportionate
changes the outcome of people's
businesses in this room.
The reason so many people are struggling
within that environment,
is they don't realize that
it's the creative, that is
the variable of success.
People are so caught up
right now in the digital
and math environment,
and they think about the,
you know, way that we
can target or the digital
money that we spend against amplification.
They don't realize that the
single piece of creative,
or the creative that they're putting out
is the variable of success.
I'm running ads, I'll give you an example,
I sell sneakers in a JV
that I have with K Swiss,
there's an ad I ran on Instagram
where by changing the adjective,
excuse me by changing the
word hustle to work ethic,
the conversion the cost of
acquisition went from $77 to $22.
We're talking about changing
a word in the sentence.
Most people running a
single piece of picture,
across all these different
platforms, or video,
and expecting results when the reality is
, what we're living in right now,
if you leave with anything,
whether you do it internal
or you do it external,
if you are a company in
2020, and you have locations,
like most of you do,
if you're not producing
50 to 100 pieces of content, a day
for Twitter, Facebook,
Instagram, YouTube, you are
leaving so much uncomfortable
opportunity on the table.
Yet, I would argue because
I did my own homework,
that there's not a lot
of companies in this room
that made 100 pieces of content in a year
for these platforms that are different.
They might have posted 100 times
but they posted the same things.
So, there is an enormous
delta of opportunity.
(iPhone ringing)
Hey guys, sorry to interrupt your video.
I'm just giving you
this call from my number
to let you know that you have
to join my text community.
212-931-5731,
hit me up with a text.
One thing that this room
has to ask themselves,
is the following.
Are they sales driven organizations,
or are they brand driven organizations.
So many people here, and with
a great sponsor to
introduce me, I love sales,
I love Google, Google's great.
Somebody's typing in they want a burger
in their local area, like
it's nice to show up,
it's good to show up.
That's sales, let there be no confusion.
There are so many people in this room
that are wildly missing
the delta between a sales
and a marketing organization.
And marketing and branding always gets
destroyed by CFOS and
short term operators.
Right, nobody I mean, this is why it's fun
to deliver keynotes like
this and have lights on,
seeing the reactions we all know.
Nobody's got the patience
to let marketing play out.
We live in such a quaint, every 90 days,
kind of environment.
If you're lucky on 90 days.
The reality though is if
you look at the businesses,
the brands that people are baffled by,
I see my man from Ann Pizza or
Kona Ice or all these things
that people are just surprised
that it's doing so well.
They are dramatically more brand driven
than they are transactional.
I mean I'm just fascinated by
our inability as a collective
to understand that and
create new ways to measure
businesses, to create new
ways to measure success.
So for me, the biggest
thing is very simple.
We're living in a time where this device
controls our consumers' every move.
You may not like it personally.
I watch people every day
and executives every day
make business decisions based on how they
socially want the world to be.
I don't have a whole
lot of emotion that kids
don't go outside and play like we did,
because we're old now.
Like that doesn't really drive me.
I'm unemotional about
my ideological nirvana,
of how the world should be.
I operate, when I put my business suit on,
which is not necessarily a suit.
I operate based on the
reality of the consumer,
not the way I want it to
be or what got me here
over the last decade.
My dad's liquor store
was built on direct mail
and full page ads in the New York Times.
Over my success people think
I did it with social media
and I did and it mattered post game,
but I built a very large business,
I built just for context for
the business people room,
my dad's liquor store
was doing $3.3 million
in revenue on 10% gross profit.
Shoppers discount liquors, he meant it.
Right?
3.3 on 10% gross.
I took that business in a six year period
from that to a $62 million a year business
running on 27% gross profit,
without a credit line,
and with no cash infusion
from BC, or private equity.
How?
I mean every marketing
penny work like a dollar.
At first I figured out
how to do direct mail
in the way that I'm
telling you to do social.
What I figured out as a child, in essence,
was that if I made seven different flyers
that were more contextual to the addresses
in New Jersey that I was sending,
that if I sent high end
wine to Short Hills,
it would do better than if I sold
every day wine to Middlesex,
it would do better.
My cost of the creative was higher,
and my dad and everybody
else made fun of me for it
because you should pay
as little as possible
for the print, the postage cost the most.
But what I even understood
inherently then as a kid
was that the context of
the creative mattered,
not just the ability for them to see it.
So my conversion rates
were dramatically bigger.
That led me to the biggest
nirvana, which was in 1997
I started a very
significant email newsletter
because that was a new phenomenon.
How many people here
were on email in 1997?
Raise your hands, just curious.
So for the hands of the room,
for the youngsters in here,
let me tell you about
us who had email in 97.
We read every single email.
Remember that?
It was new, we read it, we
treated it like actual mail.
How many people here are
close to their email marketing
or have done email
marketing in their career?
One more time.
Great, ready for this, 90% open rates.
90% open rates in 1997.
bBt like I know the sun
will come up tomorrow
I know that marketers ruin everything.
And I spent the next decade ruining email
and taking that from 90% to 30%,
because you know at first it was five days
a week email and that was incredible
and then one miraculous
day a year or two in
I was driving to the store and I'm like
people read email on Saturday.
And so we added the weekend,
and then the breakdown fall of 2004,
when I decided people
read email twice a day.
And we started emailing twice a day
and you know exactly
where this story goes,
and so learning the
pattern behavior with that,
when Google AdWords came
out, the day it came out,
I bought ads and I owned the word wine
for five cents a click, for a month
before Google made a 10 cents floor,
and before anybody even knew it existed.
Because I understood context,
I was then also good once everybody came
in buying Silver Oak 1994
Napa Valley Cabernet,
and those are my conversions
at five and 10 cents.
That long tail contextual mentality
is the biggest thing that's
missing from marketing today.
The number one reason most people in here
are wasting most of their money is A,
they're distributing it
somewhere people don't see,
which is whether remnant TV direct mail,
you know, print or see it
at a cost that's effective
in comparison to their business,
or two when they go
digital, they go vanilla.
It is so easy to make a piece of creative
that targets an Asian
American within a one mile
radius of your store, and actually
have Asian Americans in the creative.
It is easy to contextualize your creative,
you have to go in a different mindset,
you have to put the
dollars into the creative
not into the media amplification,
that is against old best practices of the
last 50 years of marketing,
but that's because
the last 50 years of marketing were
a television down mentality,
and now we're an internet,
consumer first up mentality,
we must create relevance,
not potential reach.
We must create relevance,
not potential reach,
you have to tell me why.
You put something about the
New York Jets in your creative,
I'm going to eat your hamburger.
You mentioned something
that we beat the Cowboys,
I'm in a real good mood, right?
Today, contextual.
The speed in which that kind of creative,
to get consumers to do something is
not inherently native to this industry.
As a matter of fact, it's not inherently
native the most industries,
except the emerging direct
to consumer brands that live
mainly on Instagram today.
Now, those businesses
are vulnerable because
they've raised so much capital,
they're willing to
overpay for their customer
and they're actually underwater,
something that most of us
don't have the luxury for.
But because of that they become lazy
and they also do not make
enough contextual creative,
because they can afford to buy somebody
that's worth less to them.
We cannot.
However, what really is fascinating about
actually taking this
consumer centric approach
is this doesn't just matter in marketing.
For example, I'm dying
to know in this industry,
when it's going to figure out that every
late afternoon and every evening
it has a very interesting
expiring piece of inventory
that can be converted in
massive customer acquisition.
If I owned one of the
businesses in this room,
the plan that I would have around food
that we throw out as
an offense to surprise
and delight my local
community and customers
and record those surprises and delights,
and amplify that creative
would be at the top
of the things that I would do.
You're talking about an asset,
you're talking about an asset.
What we don't have as a mentality
of creating and campaigning
and making ideas live,
fast, recorded, and amplified.
But we live in a world
where everybody in this room
has an asset that is expiring every night,
and having the speed in
which turning that asset
into a surprise and delight
moment without undermining
the core product, so
that people wait for it
is an incredibly delicate
and important strategy
that I highly recommend people debate on.
Very simply to make it literal,
taking whatever product
you sell and driving it
somewhere that evening
and giving the high school
football team the product before the game
and filming that reaction and
then posting it on Facebook
and targeting the local
area about that moment
becomes the emotional
trigger that makes somebody
consider your place that hadn't before.
It matters.
The other thing I'm
fascinated by is menu items.
I'm fascinated by the math around that
first item that drops
off, that isn't core,
that you're always trying
to figure out if we
can get one more item to the core,
what that means to our economics
and the ability to create
marketing around that
sixth, seventh, eighth item.
When you go away from making one vanilla
brand piece of content
to a world of thousands,
all of a sudden your onion rings strategy
creatively becomes a real game.
Very, very, very, important,
very, very opportunistic.
This leads me down a path that
I'd like to get the people
in this room to think about
which is the following.
If you do not understand
that you are a media company
first, comma, then a fast casual,
then a QSR, then a restaurant business,
you will become very vulnerable.
I believe what you're
seeing happen in society,
politics, social issues, everything,
it's happening in front of your face.
What's happening is
communication is the number
one, two, three, and
four things that matter.
I believe pretty executives in this room
that what I'm talking about right now
is not the kind of thing
that you go and hire
an agency for or put
your niece in charge of.
This is something you
yourself have to spend
50 to 100 hours to deeply understand
because I believe being
able to communicate
in a contemporary
fashion continues to grow
in importance on the
outcomes of businesses
and is now as equally as
important as being able
to pay your taxes, balance your checkbook,
and breathe oxygen within
a business environment.
I believe that marketing has now become
an operational function that if you really
look at what's happening,
it is unbelievably
impossible to be successful
without having your comms strategy tight,
strong, and remarkably effective.
I laugh at the old adages
of, like, you know,
I think it's David
Ogilvy or whatever it is,
that the old adage of marketing right,
we spend all this money
but 50% of it I waste,
I just don't know what 50%.
That makes a lot of sense
to me as now as a historian
of the marketing world, the
television, print, radio,
that makes zero sense in 2020.
I know where every penny does
everything about everything.
And more importantly, this is not a sales
and conversion game,
this is a branding game.
Let me explain what I mean by that.
Another tidbit that I
would love for this room
to leave with is the following.
The biggest mistake that people make
when they do digital
marketing is they think
of it as a sales channel.
A lot of people go into deal
mode, or conversion mode,
to prove its ROI, and what they're doing
is they're hurting their brand,
and they're training
their consumers to buy
their product on a cycle which hurts
all of our collective margins.
If you look at what I do with my content
or what other successful
businesses are doing.
I'm treating social as
a branding platform,
not as a sales platform.
The content I'm putting out there is
to build brand, not sales.
That is a very unique execution
that I'm seeing in the marketplace.
Too many people look at
TV, or naming rights,
or putting your company's name on jerseys,
or whatever it might
be as the branding play
but digital as the
lower funnel sales play.
The rep, you know the thing
you take away from the
deals that you would have
done on print or direct mail.
I believe that is a huge vulnerability
and that what people
need to understand is the
only way you've ever
built a brand in society
is you have somebody's attention,
and then you tell a story.
The attention is very clear where it is.
I want to remind the
hands that went up here.
Television commercials are the most
overpriced way to communicate
in today's society.
I understand that it
dominated, I loved it too.
I'd be thrilled to do
it, it's, by the way,
I wish I was growing
up in the 60s and 70s.
All I had to do was convince
you to do business with me,
and then it was easy, one 30 second spot.
Piece of cake.
You know how much more fun it is
and how much more profitable it is
for an agency to do a 30 second spot
versus doing thousands
of pieces of creative.
It's a lot easier.
The problem is, it's not
where the consumer is today.
And now I'm going to segue into
the real elephant in the room for me.
When this came out, I ended
up making a lot of money.
This came out, and I said the smartphone
was going to be the most
important thing ever.
I wish I was making content back there
because a lot of you
will admit to yourself
that you thought this.
When this came out almost
every single business friend
that I had told me it would fail
because the BlackBerry
was so goddamn good.
That they couldn't feel
the buttons on this.
And they got so good at blackberry didn't
even have to look anymore and they'll
never give up that Blackberry.
What I know is that
technology always wins.
Always.
There is a looming
technology in our society
that I think is going to be an absolute
tidal wave to this industry.
That technology is the
first platform since this
that I believe I'm taking
as serious as I took this.
This came out, and the
first three companies
I invested in in 2007 and 08
were Facebook, Twitter, and Tumblr,
it obviously changed
the course of my life.
Today I sit as a snake in
the grass like I like to
waiting for Alexa, Google Home, Apple pod,
or whatever voice AI device
actually wins our society norms,
to actually hit scale.
How many people here have
a Google Home or an Alexa,
raise your hands.
Now, this is great.
Now, as all of you know
because the majority of
this room does have one.
Right now, that device is very similar
to the first year two of the iPhone.
To remind everybody about
year one on the iPhone
and the App Store, the number
one app for a long time,
was the app that looked like a beer
was on your phone and you drank it.
I think people get caught by technology,
by not understanding how it usually works.
I think we can all agree
right now that Alexa
and Google Home were for the most part
treating it pretty basic.
We're asking for some music,
our kids are doing some stuff,
but this is not the most important thing
in your life right now.
However, I argue much like
what evolved with the iPhone,
that the device in the
home is going to accelerate
over the next decade in
a very significant way,
that when you start realizing
that your Google calendar
is attached to your Google Home device,
and you can just tell Google to schedule
a dentist appointment,
and it will understand
what the perfect time to schedule it is,
and reach out to your
dentist and slot it in,
very quickly over the next
decade, we will get very used
to the number one thing
we have chosen forever,
which is why last model
and delivery is becoming
such a big part of your business,
which is convenience is king.
I don't have to tell this
industry with drive through,
or what the nature of a lot
of this industry to begin with
versus clicking at home,
convenience will always win.
The convenience structure of
the voice device in our society
is going to be a very big deal.
And more importantly, it
will lead to the thing
that I care about the most which is
in a world of voice,
the only thing left will be brand.
When the UI is no longer
visual and it is audio,
only brand will succeed.
Let me explain.
It should be everybody's
great fear in this room
that an eight years, if I'm
sitting in my living room
and have decided to order food,
if I say, Alexa order me a pizza,
Alexa, order me, chicken,
Alexa order me a burger,
you better damn well
spend the next decade,
making sure what comes out of my mouth
is Alexa order me a
Shake Shack, or a Five,
or an And, or a Kona,
you better get there,
because you do not want
Alexa, and Google, and Apple
deciding which pizza, which Chinese food,
which pancakes I get
delivered because either A,
the cost of that toll
booth will be so great
that you will not be able to afford it,
or B, and far more likely
B, it will send to me,
the company that they
have financial vested
interest in because they own it.
I believe over the next decade,
we will be in a place 10 years from today,
and real quick how many
people in this room
are retiring in the next
five to seven years,
and I don't mean, you're going to crush
the execution of your company
and flip it and buy an island.
I mean, I mean you're just
fucking old and you're finished.
Okay, got two, or three, four.
Okay, so for the four of you that
enthusiastically raised your hands, five,
you can take some of these
thoughts with a grain of salt,
other than I do believe
there's so much opportunity
right now to spend your money more wisely
to get customers in,
but for the rest of you,
I highly recommend you pay
attention very carefully
to the last three
minutes, and the next two
which is the following.
I promise you, and I'm saying this not
to do anything other than because
I know D-Rock is recording right now,
and I'm going to air this
in 10 years on whatever
the Instagram of the day
is to say I told you so.
I promise you that in
a decade, 15 years max,
brand, your brand is going to be the
only thing that matters,
besides the quality of your product.
Everything else in the
middle will be commoditized.
And as you know, the margin,
and the subjectiveness
around the quality of your
product is very uncontrollable.
There are people that prefer
a White Castle over a $35 burger.
So that's subjective
and very marginal based,
what is not is your
capability of building a brand
that comes out of my tongue.
If you do not go 100% in the
mentality of building brand,
you will be uncomfortably vulnerable.
The cost of entry to be
in your space is about to
collapse because of the
virtual kitchens at scale.
People will build brands and market
and everything else will
be a commodity, they will.
And that's the truth.
And so I highly recommend
that this morning,
we really get serious.
I come to every speech the same way
which is I'm so flattered to be there,
I'm so humbled to be
compensated the way I am,
I'm desperate to bring the most value.
And the way that I know
how to do that is to put
the truths that are actually
happening in the system
and are obvious to me on a
plate in front of the audience,
I know that 95% of the
people do nothing about it.
But I am telling you
right now, for the 5% here
that will consider it, here's the formula.
Here's the prescription.
You have to become some, you, you,
have to become somebody
that knows how to run ads
and makes pictures,
videos and audio on these
10 social networks,
from LinkedIn, Facebook,
Twitter, YouTube, you, you
have to understand it cold.
You cannot outsource this,
because how will you hire people
or hire partners to do it if
you don't know how to judge it.
One of the great things
of growing up in retail
was I did everything.
One of the great things about Vayner Media
is I didn't know that
strategy, and creative,
and account, and media
were separate functions,
I did them all for myself.
I love the feeling of
waking up every morning
knowing if everyone
quits I know what to do.
You cannot be in this room
today, and have people quit
and not know how to communicate
and market your company.
It's over, the cats out of the bag.
It's what's left.
And so, all that effort into figuring out
the perfect location because of traffic
and all that arbitrage, or
the decorations of within,
or all those things, they still matter,
but every second that
goes by they matter less,
and the ability to know how to
run an Instagram swipe up ad
for $3 CPM within a four
mile radius of your store
against 44 different pieces of creative
to make all those citizens feel contextual
to then convert into traffic
and higher receipt spend,
that matters more, and will continue to.
If you don't have a Tik
Tok, and LinkedIn strategy
for your restaurants right
now, you're making a mistake,
because they're the two places that have
the most organic reach,
where you don't even
have to pay for media to build awareness.
Both seem wildly crazy for this sector
based on what they are.
LinkedIn has historically been a B2B
recruiting place which has now
become really Facebook 2012
and Tik Tok everybody thinks
is just for 11 year olds,
just like we used to think Facebook was
only for college kids.
Don't even get me started on the fact
that the 12 to 14 year
old girl in a family,
usually influences the mom's
buying decisions, and she's
the one that actually buys
for the whole household.
Please let's get more thoughtful,
please understand where this is going.
If you have not committed to truly acting
like a media company,
producing content at scale,
your competitor will.
I'm seeing it already.
And when we really get at
scale of the infrastructure
that allows me or anybody else to compete,
without all the upfront costs of locations
and decorations and all
the other variables,
it's going to get very
competitive really fast.
Please do not do what a
room full of retailers,
and a room full of taxi and limo drivers
have done in the past,
please do not take this talk
for not the seriousness that I come with.
And by the way, I have no
interest in being Debbie downer.
This is more of change your strategy,
understand what's happening,
you have plenty of time.
We're not there yet, but
don't do what everybody does,
and use that time to
be passive and hopeful,
a strategy of this never works.
And I know this room is smart.
I know you don't want it to happen.
I don't want anything, I
don't want every winery
to ship their products direct to consumer,
that'd be bad for my dad's business,
but I think they should.
If you're capable why
not keep all the margin?
I know you don't want it.
The problem is the customer does.
And that is the rub.
Thank you.
(audience clapping)
- I'm freaking old but
I'm not finished yet.
So, in your app, if you go to the Gary,
(stammers)
Gary session at the very bottom,
they're going to have a Q&A,
we've already got
questions coming in there,
please add your question there
and we will go from there.
We've already got several.
- [Gary] Let's go.
- Gary, what do you think
of Bitcoin and blockchain
and how is it going to change the world?
- So I bought Bitcoin in 2014,
so that was good, I wish about more.
I think blockchain is the
one technology in our society
that I'm aware of that has
the ability to be as big
if not bigger than the internet.
I also think it's super far away.
I also believe that
America, Russia, and China
will do everything in its
power to not let it hit scale,
because if you really
understand the technology
of blockchain, it cuts everything
out of the middle including government.
And I think that it's a
very exciting technology,
it is the acceleration
of the internet itself,
because what the internet did was allow
the Facebooks and the
Googles and the Apples to be,
in essence, the middle,
and then everybody else
is the tollbooth collector
to their toll booths.
But I think it's going
to be a big technology
but I think it's gonna take
a very long time to manifest.
And I think a lot of money will be lost in
cryptocurrency because
just like search engines
and browsers, thousands
died, one or two emerged,
but I think it's going to be here.
I don't think it's something,
look, the things that,
even the fact that I talked about voice
is not what I normally
do, I tend to talk about
do LinkedIn and Tik Tok right now.
Buy influencers on Instagram still,
it's not over it hasn't even started.
It's like that tactical.
The reason I wanted to
bring up voice today
even though I think it's
five or seven years away,
is because it leads you
down the inevitable path of
why brand creative is
what I want you to do,
not transactional.
- From Aaron, quality or speed,
if you can pick only one what would it be?
- Speed.
Speed's not subjective, quality is.
- [Host] Simple enough.
- It is, it's very simple.
I live with it every day.
What is quality creative,
is what, you know,
like people, like my
senior creative's like
well this isn't quality.
I'm like based on who, you?
Speed is non-debatable, quality is,
until it hits the market,
and then you could see if its quality.
Hence why a religion around
1000 pieces of content,
let the consumer show you what's
working, not your audacity.
- Sally asked how will
this changing environment
affect supply chain management?
- To me, Sally, you'll appreciate this,
I haven't spent a whole lot of time
on supply chain management.
Obviously there's technology advances.
I am, as you can see I speak
with enormous conviction
around what I'm passionate about,
which is I spend 100% of my
time on consumer behavior,
what customers are doing what they're
paying attention to, how they're acting.
I just haven't spent enough time
to give a great answer on that.
- What would book, besides your own,
which I basically have here, so that,
but besides your own what
book would you recommend,
or what source should
people go to for information
on social media efficacy?
- I'll give you, actually
I wouldn't even read,
it depends on, like I would
never read my own book
because I don't learn
by reading books, I so,
I think you have to first be
self aware of how you learn,
but I'll give you a website
that will crush this
for you because you
could literally type in
what does a 10 location
hot dog business do
on LinkedIn like it's incredible,
I'll spell it for you G,
O, O, G, L, E, dot com.
I believe that Google for
the inevitable questions
in this room are remarkable.
If you literally typed in tonight
how do I run ads on Facebook to raise
average transaction spend,
you will actually get results.
And then you can decide
if you're a good reader,
or if you're more like me
and will watch a video,
the free information on the internet
is always better than a book in my opinion
because it's contemporary.
I wasn't, you know, what can
you throw my last, my slide?
I want to show you guys something
that's very interesting,
my last book, Crushing It,
which came out about 18 months ago 24,
I don't really know, two years.
Nonetheless, if you look above it,
it's got a bunch of
logos, that's Instagram,
Snapchat, Facebook, Twitter,
podcasting and YouTube.
If you look at that book
which is only 24 months old,
I'm talking about the real blueprint
of what you should be doing,
yet, LinkedIn, and Tik Tok are not in it.
Yet, it's the only thing
that I want most of you
to do right now if you
don't want to spend money.
So, to answer that
question, one of the things,
like, again, I day trade attention.
I believe most people do marketing
like they buy mutual funds,
they make a decision and
then they go to sleep.
I'm making decisions every day, every day,
you know, Instagram's organic reach
is clearly starting to decline.
So this golden era of four,
five, six years of Instagram,
I believe is now starting to look like
what Facebook did a couple years ago,
I have to, I'm day trading,
because the customers living every day,
every day, a new competitors
popping up against you,
every day, a new diet reports coming out,
this is an everyday thing.
- From an anonymous caller
to our channel here.
With all the focus on AI and convenience,
third party delivery, etc.
What in your opinion, it just moved on me.
What in your opinion drives
someone to get out there,
get out of their house or office,
and come into a brick and mortar?
In other words, what's the most
important to the experience?
- Convenience.
Like if your locations
happened to be right
outside my office and I want to go,
like, convenience is still king.
Experience, I believe that all of us,
you know, and I say us because my family
has a retail business like are going to,
I'm trying to, we have this
huge two story wine shop,
and I'm trying to convince my dad to turn
the second floor into
something completely different,
because you need some
rationale for somebody to come.
Look, people are going to
continue to go to places and eat.
My problem is, I'm worried
how the math plays out
based on the costs you put into that.
My point to the retailers was people,
guys, gals, people still shop,
the square footage costs
doesn't make sense in 2019,
like it did in 2010, right?
So it doesn't take a
lot of behavior changes
for you to be underwater on your COGs.
Not complicated.
So convenience, so I still
think that will matter.
And I think uniqueness.
I believe will be a day
where you charge for less
than the food in your place
than you do for delivery,
because you're going to
try to hack them coming in.
And that's going to
create even more friction
and so like there's so
many of these, like,
you've got to be consumer
centric this is what they want.
So now how do you do that.
I believe that it's convenience
and I think it's about programming.
I think a lot of us are
going to get into program,
listen, people want to go out.
People want to go out more than ever.
People want to go out to
show that they're out,
you've seen the extreme
like dessert places
that are doing well,
because their locations
are doing well because
people want to take a photo
and put it on Instagram.
People are hiking more than ever.
They don't want to fucking
hike, they just want the photo.
So I say use the psychology
of consumer behavior.
One of the things that
I would highly recommend
is create one new item on your menu
that is so ludicrous looking
that it makes people take
photos, which is the real
reason they come to your place.
I'll tell you another thing
about doing content every day.
I started something that
I want all of you to steal
called What If Wednesday.
I think every business here
should start something
called What If Wednesday,
and you make up a food product
you don't actually sell,
draw it up, or actually
make it if you're capable,
put it out, see what happens.
Now you're doing R&D on menu
items at a very low cost.
This is about ideas and making things.
- For brand cultivation,
how do you navigate
the current politicization of the media?
- You know, look, I think
America is on full tilt,
we're separating at our seams
and you've got to be thoughtful,
you've got to recognize that
if you enter into that fray,
half your customer base
is going to go on tilt.
That's how you navigate it.
And if you feel compelled
that that's what you need
to do for your for you as a
human, you're more than welcome.
I jump into certain things,
I stay out of other things,
you know, as we're seeing
with the NBA in China,
you know like, they're very
passionate about some issues,
they're going the other way
on when it hits their wallet.
Like you know this is real life.
This is real life.
So my advice on this is very simple.
You do you.
You know what you how
you care about your life,
your family, your legacy.
Recognize that history
will look at all of this,
so you're gonna have to talk
to your grandkids one day
but at the same token, you
can't be ideological about this.
We are at a point right now
where we are completely in half.
And if you go hard on something,
half of it will go the other way.
And that's fine, that's happened before.
You know, I recommend everybody doing
more history lessons on the Vietnam War,
and how businesses
navigated during that time
and things that nature,
obviously with social
there's more amplification,
there's more instantaneousness.
This is not a place, this is a place,
much like everything I
said, I'll be very frank,
I'm actually going to say
something funny to you.
I was about to say, look,
I'm not trying to impose,
I'm trying to observe, not
saying what's right or wrong,
no different than what I just
spent the entire keynote on.
Ironically, the best
thing that could happen
for me selfishly is none of
you take any of my advice,
because all of this is just one stream,
and if you start running ads
and you start doing creative,
the cost of my content goes up.
And that's my biggest point.
I'm very worried for SMBs
and midsize businesses
not realizing what comes
next, which is the following.
When Coca Cola, and GE, and Ford,
and the biggest companies
in the world really
realize what's going on,
and they shift their budgets
really here, the cost of
getting in front of people
is going to go up exponentially.
It's what happened on search.
It's really good for us early people,
and then the big companies got in
and all sudden 10 cent words became $14.
- Somebody's reading our minds out there.
You've got 2 million to
spend on media and creative.
How much would you be
spending on content creative?
- That's a great question.
I need to, you know, I
hate blanket macro stuff
but let me say this,
way more than you think.
I probably be, just on sheer
starting the conversation.
I'm far more in the 30 to
50% than I am 20% and below.
Content is the variable of success.
The media when bought right,
here's where I'm passionate,
I believe most of the
companies are overpaying
for media both in programmatic
digital and with traditional.
I think there's a better way to buy it
in day trading on marketplaces,
on Facebook, Google,
YouTube, Instagram, Snap, all
these things, LinkedIn, right?
So all of a sudden I'm saving you,
I'm actually getting in front of people
versus potentially getting
in front of people,
which then I can take
that savings and make
a lot more contextual creative.
and instead of making one
vanilla piece that cost 35,000,
I can make 887 that costs
35,000 and scale, scale, scale.
- Internet trolls.
- Yep.
- Ignore, engage, provoke,
or let your fans deal with them for you?
- First, with internet
trolls, the first thing
I deploy is empathy, because
if you're a human being
that is actually taking time
out of your day to consume
something, and then spit
venom, you're life's fucked.
Number two, I think you should engage it.
I engage trolls, I feed my trolls,
because I don't think of them as trolls.
I think of them as dissenting voices that
can show all the consumers where I stand.
More importantly, first you
have to look in the mirror
and figure out if they're right.
Very early on I had a soup
client, and it was 2009,
if you remember early Facebook,
if you posted something on a person's page
it would show up like a
wall like old MySpace,
and they posted pictures
of animals being caged
that they were using
for their food products.
And I get this crazy email
that I have to be on,
you know they just started
social, this was all so new,
and I'm on the phone with
the board and the CEO,
and they're like you have to fix this.
And I'm like, no problem.
Let me ask you some questions.
Number one, is this true?
Yeah but you got to fix it.
And I go, I can't.
It's not how the world
is going to work anymore.
So, um, I don't look at it
as trolls, I look at as,
you know, listen, when
people are saying egregious
things that make no sense,
you don't need to engage,
but if people are
complaining about service,
or people complaining
about something didn't
taste right or things that nature,
I think it's actually
very smart to engage,
so that everybody else can
see that you're listening,
and you stand by your product because when
you're not replying or
deleting and hiding.
You're always one
screenshot away of deleting
a negative comment,
becoming a much bigger story
than the fact that somebody
didn't like the tomato soup.
- [Host] You're a strong
figurehead for your company,
a social media voice.
Question is can explosive
success be achieved
without a human person
representing the brand?
- Mainly it does.
Very few companies actually use a CO
for her him to be the face.
There's, almost every company
doesn't have a figurehead.
- Would you have any advice for executives
in themselves approaching social media
for helping out their company and sales?
- First be self aware.
If you're introverted
and you don't like it,
and it's not your scene,
you don't have to do it.
Second, if you have gift
of gab and you like it
and you love people, you should do it,
but recognize that you have to
spit 100% truth at all times,
or you are vulnerable.
- [Host] What should a small
independent restaurant post on
LinkedIn, and this also could
be referred chain restaurant.
- Yeah, I mean, look, LinkedIn is crazy
organically right now.
Post, I always think about it this way,
post something that brings people value.
So, if you're an independent restaurant,
there's a lot of things that can be value.
Your head chef is funny,
and you could just videotape her or him.
You could show how you make your product
if you're proud of that.
And now you get into the
recipes and making business,
you could talk about local stuff.
I still believe most of
you should be the mayor
of your town on Facebook and LinkedIn.
Where like, ready, one store
location in Kansas City,
that posts on LinkedIn or
Facebook about the pothole
on Main Street, and everybody
rallies around that laugh,
which then leads to them maybe
fixing the pothole at
night with their employees,
and now becomes a localized event.
So, so it doesn't have to
just be about your business,
it has to be part of the community,
much like restaurants have
always done a good job with,
the same reason that you
sponsor the softball team
is the same reason you should make content
about how awesome the
principal is, or the pothole,
or blah, blah, blah.
Media company, remember,
I know it's heady,
so I keep trying to reinforce it.
You're a media company,
comma, your a restaurant.
Now all of a sudden you can
talk about sports and weather.
You're the news, you can be.
You really can.
And of course if you can
do it about your recipes,
because you're, you're so
proud of your products,
that's going to lead to success.
- How do traditional
marketers shake it off,
is their conversion therapy?
- Yes, I think it's a side hustle.
If you're a traditional marketer
and you're like, I just,
I would start a side hustle
of buying some product
and trying to sell it
on Shopify and Amazon
and running ads on Facebook and Instagram
to then taste what it really works like.
Side hustles, where do you force yourself
to play small because
you've always played big,
and you've lost touch with reality
and you're in theoretics.
- The industry right now seeing a lot of
virtual kitchens, ghost
kitchens, dark kitchens.
What can the executives
do to deal with this
and how do you explain that phenomenon.
- This is the single most
important issue in this room.
This is going to be real bad.
I really believe that.
The only thing I think you can do
is while you've got the
advantage and you exist,
versus your competitors
that don't exist yet,
you have to out brand them now.
I'm telling you right now you have to.
And you have to be
thoughtful in your expansion.
If you're going to build out, you know,
more locations, you have
to be more thoughtful
of the cost of goods of opening that up
when you're going to be competing against
people that don't have that cost.
And they're going to pour
that money into marketing.
This is big.
I can't stress on you enough
how you need to look at your P&L,
find as many dollars as
humanly possible for marketing,
and then be great at it.
I can't, I you know,
I don't think I've been
around the bush this morning.
You have to become an actual
practitioner and strategist
and understander of contemporary branding,
because these virtual kitchens
are going to be a real problem.
They really are, you're going
to have 10 new competitors tomorrow,
who are going to take all the money
you spend on location and staff,
and all this other stuff
and put it directly
into getting consumers to pick
their product versus yours.
This is very real.
I've been telling this
to CPGs for a long time
about Amazon and Shopify and they laughed,
and they we're much
bigger companies than you,
and they're competing gets
much smaller infrastructure,
and they're being affected,
this infrastructure is far better.
And you're far smaller
than Procter and Unilever
and Kraft them Pepsi.
This is real.
I don't want this to be like a ugh,
this needs to be, I need to go act.
I need to build my brand at all costs.
- [Host] We have 14 seconds left,
will the Jets ever be relevant?
- I think that's fair based
on my tone this morning.
Of course, I will buy
the Jets and 22 years,
I will win a Super Bowl.
I will grab the Lombardi
trophy look in the camera,
look at all of you and say, I told you.
Thank you.
Thank you for this morning,
I wish you success.
(audience clapping)